here
Good morning.
For all of you who don't know me. My name's Alan
Ross, and I've been a Pastor Elder here at Henderson Hills
for 20 years.
I've recently also come to realize that I've officially been preaching
at one church or another for exactly 50 years.
All that together means that I'm old.
Our sermon today is going to start with a little story from
my life back in the 1990s back
when I had hair my lovely wife
Deedee and I bought our first house as a place for two
little daughters to grow up in.
We were poor then but Devi and I took the plunge when
we bought a home here in Edmond.
It was a real fixer upper a
HUD home that no one had wanted for a long time.
A few years passed with a lot of little repairs,
but without a major crisis then one
fine day we noticed there was a crack along
the corner brickwork outside. My
daughter's bedroom.
Together we came to the horrifying conclusion that
there was a growing crack in the foundation of
our home.
Oh.
After doing some investigating I found out that our hard red
Oklahoma dirt isn't as hard as it might seem.
The ground beneath us is really a giant sponge that
can dry out and shrink in the Oklahoma sun or
think of it as a giant slab of
uncooked bacon that dries out as it
flies becoming thin and small and crunchy like
the little bookmarks size strips
of bacon on your breakfast plate.
We are experiencing a bad drought at the time in the ground beneath
my house had dried out and it
was taking the corner of my daughter's bedroom
down as it shrunk.
When I found all this out, I was devastated.
Disaster was going to cost us thousands of
dollars to have a foundation or paired company
come in and jack up the corner of that house with
beams or peers.
We didn't have that kind of money.
I was in such shock. I went through the five stages
of grief.
Denial maybe the cracks in the bricks are just cosmetic. Let's
wait a few years and see.
Anger, why is this happening to us? We
just had inspectors checked the foundation of the
house when we bought it. This isn't our vault. It just has
unfair.
Bargaining maybe I can get a shovel and work all summer
and Paul lots of dirt along the outside and that will fix
the problem.
depression
no shovel is going to fix this massive crack
that leads all the way down to Flaming Hades.
We are doomed.
And finally acceptance. Okay. We just got
to make the commitment borrow the money hire a
foundation repair company to fix this disaster.
As I Research Foundation repair companies I discovered there
were two types the cheaper companies who dug a
little deeper into the red Oklahoma dirt and the
more expensive companies who dug all the way down
to the Bedrock which some people call the
living Rock.
Since the ground itself was shrinking it didn't
make any sense to me to go with a company. That was just going
to dig deeper into that shrinking dirt.
So I made the commitment.
Paid out a lot of money and had an
expensive company to dig and go deep
laying the beams directly into
the living bedrock.
When I preach I always like to start with a short simple thesis. So
everyone can follow what I'm trying to say this morning.
My thesis is just seven words long and it's this make
the commitment dig and
go deep.
Our verses for the morning come from the Gospel of Luke chapter
6 verses 46 through 49 just
four little verses where Jesus is preaching his
famous Sermon on the Mount which is the longest
recorded sermon Jesus ever preached.
These four verses are the very last words of
The Sermon on the Mount so they serve as a kind of a culmination
of Jesus's whole sermon a
call to action for his audience to actually do
the things that he is just preached upon.
In this passage Jesus starts out with his
thesis and then he tells a parable to help us understand
the thesis a parable
as you know is a specialty of Jesus. It's a little story
which serves as a sermon illustration.
The story is called a kind of an analogy or allegory
where each literal aspect of
the story often means something figuratively or
symbolically.
As Pastor John has been explaining to us in
this series The Sermon seem like simple often sweet
little stories, but they're really designed to
separate bad thinking and behavior from good
thinking and behavior.
Parables are like a razor-sharp state knife which
Cuts away the bad stuff the fat the
gristle and the bone leaving behind the good
stuff the juicy Cattleman's porterhouse
steak.
So let's read the passage together starting in verse 46.
Why do you call me Lord Lord and
do not do what I tell you.
Everyone who comes to me and hears my words and does them
I will show you what he's like.
He's like a man building a house who dug deep
and lay the foundation on the rock.
And when a flood arose this dream broke against
the house.
And could not shake it because the house had been
well-built.
But the one who hears and does not do them is like a man
who built a house on the ground without a foundation.
When the stream broke against it immediately it
fell and the ruin of that house
was great.
As you can see Jesus starts with his thesis in
verse 46. Why do you call me
Lord Lord and do not do what I
tell you.
The New Testament was written in ancient Greek and the Greek word for Lord
here is carry.
At the lowest level Lord just means someone in
authority over you who you are to obey like a
military commander or a king.
But at the highest level the word carrier Lord
is often used interchangeably in the New Testament
with the word god.
as it is in John 20:28 when Thomas
finally realizes that he's speaking to the actual resurrected Jesus
and Thomas exclaimed my
Lord and my God.
Therefore Jesus is our King, but he's
also our almighty God.
He has the authority to tell us what to do.
So why listen to Jesus Lord means king and
it means god?
Jesus' point is that there were people hanging out with him pretending
to be as followers, but they weren't doing the things.
Jesus was telling them to do.
Jesus is pointing out the obvious contradiction in their
lives. He was in effect using the parable to
separate the disobedient Pretender followers
cutting them out like fat and gristle and
Bone separating them from the porterhouse state
of those true followers who were
obedient to his words.
sometimes Jesus will explain the elements
or the parts of the Parables letting
this disciples know what each literal thing
in the story represents symbolically or
allegorically
But Jesus doesn't do that here.
So during the course of this sermon we have to explore what the following story
elements really mean one the builders.
the houses
the stone
the sand
the flood
Let's start with the builder who was the builder?
the builders you
the builders meet
everyone who ever lived the Builder
Lucas not the only gospel writer to record
this Parable Matthew also records a version of this Parable
in Matthew 7 verses 24 through 27.
Both Matthew and Luke make it obvious. The Builder is all
of us.
What is interesting is that Luke goes into more detail
than Matthew does and Luke's
version is also much more intense.
In Matthew simpler version as readers, we get
the general impression that over there is a chunk of Bedrock sticking
up and one guy builds this house
on that. And another direction is a stretch of
sand and the other guy builds his house on that.
In Luke's more detailed version, however, there's digging involved.
Verse 47 everyone who comes to me and hears my word
and does them I will show you what he's like, he's like
a man building a house who dug deep and
laid the foundation on the rock.
So when we analyze Luke's version of the parable
we see there are two types of ground one,
which is rock and one which is sand rather.
We see only one type of ground that both
men are building upon it is
Sandy ground with bedrock deep down
underneath the sand.
So the difference between the two Builders is not where
they chose to build but how
they chose to build. So Matthew emphasizes
where to build Luke emphasizes how
to build
In Israel in the first century and I think sometimes even
today heavy rains would fall in September
which caused all the dry riverbeds to
become torrential floods.
after these floods passed they would cause the ground on
the banks of the dry River beds to become flat
and clear and hard like
concrete making it an ideal location
for building houses when summertime
rolled around
The obvious problem is that a few months later. The September
rains would come around in the dry. River beds
would become a torrential flood once again
washing away any house built on
that treacherous sand.
The only way around the problem is for the Builder to dig and
go deep placing the buildings
Foundation directly on the living bedrock.
This would cause the seasonal torrential flood simply
to flow around the house without doing any
damage at all.
in 1838 Bible researcher, Edward
Robinson
Stayed in what is now Israel in a home that had
just been built and the builder at that time had
been forced to dig a stunning thirty feet
down through the sand to hit the
living bedrock.
Luke describes this exact process when he writes in verse
38 that the Builder on the rock
dug deep and laid the
foundation on the rock.
The English phrase Doug deep is really just one verb here.
But in the Greek of the New Testament, it's two verbs. It is
Doug and kept deepening.
Or another way of saying it is Doug and went deep.
So that's why I've worded our thesis for the day as make the
commitment dig and go deep emphasizing
the meaning of the Greek.
So Luke emphasizes digging and
going deep.
So what is the house?
The house is your life.
It is your main purpose in
life.
As we just seen Luke goes in more detail than
Matthew did.
But now we'll see that Luke also uses more intense
language.
The Holy Spirit inspired the writers of the Bible, but
he used their own personalities their
own vocabulary in their own writing styles to
express God's perfect inerrant word.
most of the writers of the New Testament were common men
like fishermen
But Luke is an educated man.
Luke is a medical doctor a physician
So God uses Luke's knowledge of medicine
to enrich the meaning of the
words of the Bible.
Luke makes it obvious that the house and the parable is to be
associated with your life with my life
because he describes the house.
Using medical terms that describe the
human body.
Luke uses four medical terms for
the human body In this passage and each time. He
uses one of these terms they're the only time the
words are used in the entire Bible.
So what is the flood in a general sense the
flood represents events or crises that
test your life?
your reason for living
So let's read verse 49 again, and I'm going
to emphasize those four words.
but the one who hears and does not do them is like
a man who built a house on the ground without a foundation when
the Stream
Broke against it immediately it fell.
And the ruin of that house was great.
The word stream physician Luke uses here as
a Greek word plumerous.
Which is a medical term when the internal body
fluids are gushing and overwhelming.
the whole body
As my dad lie in a hospital bed his lungs
filled up with fluid.
His surgeon performed an operation to drain my
dad's lungs, but the flood came again the next day and filled his
lungs all the way up again.
The surgeon told me he couldn't stop the flood.
He told me to say goodbye to my dad.
So Devi and I held each one of his hands on
either side of the bed.
And we're saying to him and we prayed for him
as he passed away.
Luke is saying that a flood is coming for all of
us and we can't stop it.
When the passage states that the blood the flood broke against
the house.
Physician Luke uses the word proserasan which is a medical
term to describe a rupture of the
veins a powerful explosion of the
veins.
A tragic example of this is an a
bursting or an explosion of a vein
in the brain and that's called an aneurysm.
Those ruptures break against the houses of those sufferers lives
was such force that that
explosion often causes them to pass away almost
immediately.
When the passage states that the house fell Luke
uses a Greek word a passion,
which is a medical term for a collapsing in
or falling in of the parts of the body.
Perhaps like when the rib cage is crushed and
it collapses the lungs.
Finally when the passage States and the ruin of that
house was great for the word ruin physician.
Luke uses the word ragma, which
is a medical term for a complete rupture
of the whole body. Perhaps like
when a landslide completely crushes the human body
into its component elements. So there's
really almost nothing left.
Let me emphasize again that these are powerful even
explosive medical terms related to
the human body related to the house and
for all four words. They're the only
time they occur in the Bible.
Lucas getting the readers here to feel like we are
in a 3D movie having the houses of
Our Lives Rock by the sheer power of
this flood and the flood as it
broke.
And the house fell.
And the whole thing was a ruin.
We want to pretend that no flood.
Is coming in our lives?
Luke is using explosive words to make us feel the
power of the coming flood.
So that we will be wise and build upon
the living Rock.
So Luke emphasizes the power and the destruction of
the flood.
What is the sand? What is The Rock?
It is what you choose as the meaning as the
foundation of your life.
What is the meaning of life?
Why are you here?
What is your purpose?
on this Earth
This is perhaps the most Central most essential question
in the history of humanity. If you
look at a poll of all the people in the world, that would
have a lot of different answers to what is
the meaning of life. Someone say
it's the pursuit of happiness.
Someone say pleasure.
Someone say oh You Need Is Love
Edmund someone say it's all about family.
It's all about work calming the ladder of
success or power or influence or
money.
Fame
someone say it's education in the life of the mind
or maybe the Arts and the humanities.
The saddest of us would say that it never occurred to us
to ask the question. What is the meaning of life?
Sometimes I'm known for saying the phrase.
Let's imagine a world where someone made the commitment but
to solve this mystery of what is the meaning of life?
Let's imagine they conducted a series of grand scientific
experiments to test every possible
answer to the meaning of life to see what
the end result is.
But interestingly we don't have to imagine such a
person.
Because he actually existed and is Grand experiment is recorded
in the pages of the Bible.
3,000 years ago King Solomon undertook a
scientific experiment and carefully records
his findings in the Old Testament book
of Ecclesiastes.
Now Solomon is uniquely qualified for this Monumental task.
He's the wisest man ever to live except for
Jesus.
He's Supreme and knowledge and scholarship. He's the greatest
King Israel ever had.
And he's richer than Elon Musk.
He's approach to solving the mystery of the meaning of life was to
take each Endeavor and to do it with all of his heart and
all of his resources and then to analyze its
ultimate value.
He threw himself into knowledge and scholarship and a pleasure
and fun. He mentions alcohol into work.
He built massive building projects like the first temple
and the Magnificent Palace.
He wielded ultimate power as king taking Authority
even over other kingdoms.
He accumulated vast riches he's sponsored
music and the Arts.
He threw himself into love and romance, perhaps
like no person ever has or should.
He had a thousand ladies to
fall in love with.
700 wives and 300 other women who kind of
played the role of wives
What is Solomon's conclusion from his
exhaustive and probably exhausting research?
He judges each candidate to the answer of
the meaning of life with his famous phrase.
vanity of vanities all is
vanity
Every one of these patches of sand however good
they are in and of themselves are all a
horrible and tragic ruin as an answer to
the meaning of life.
Every one of them is a disaster a
complete and utter.
devastation
Solomon concludes therefore most everything
is sand utterly worthless as the
foundation of life.
So now it's time to address you as the Builder
in this parable.
I ask this Universal question to you and I want
you to think seriously about it.
Why are you on this planet?
What is your purpose?
What is your meaning in life you're Foundation?
your highest priority
Let's look at Solomon's conclusion to his research into
the meaning of life. These are the very last words of the
Book of Ecclesiastes in chapter 12.
the end of the matter
all has been heard.
Fear God and keep his Commandments for this
is the whole duty of man.
For God will bring every deed into judgment
with every secret thing.
whether good
or evil
So when you dig down through the 30
feet of sand the distracting sand and you
get to the bottom of the shaft. What is the living
Rock The Living rock is God himself?
The living rock is Jesus Christ?
Solomons conclusion sounds an awful lot like
the Westminster Shorter Catechism, which a lot of us know around
here written in 1647 which encapulates all
the Bible in just a few words.
Hear the opening words of that catechism question one.
What is the chief end of man?
Answer man's Chief end is to glorify
God and enjoy him forever
to glorify God and enjoy
him forever.
So God is the only Bedrock Foundation.
for our lives
Simply put our purpose as human beings the reason for
our existence and the meaning of Our Lives
is to be in harmony.
with God our maker
and our creator
our purpose is to worship God and enjoy him
forever.
the main part of the word enjoy
Is the word Joy?
We are designed to be an absolute harmony with
God in absolute Joy with God
that is what God wants for us. And
that is what he is always wanted for us.
the bad news
The only way to have harmony with God
is to be absolutely sinless just like
him.
God is so perfect. So holy that he
cannot have harmony with people like
us who are sinful who do things say
things and think things that are
less than his absolute moral
holiness.
We're like Adam and Eve and that we choose to disobey
God. We choose other gods other
patches of sand to worship, especially worshiping
ourselves
because we fall infinitely short of God's absolutely holiness.
we all
all human beings
all of us are at war with God.
So we naturally seek to build the houses
of Our Lives on different patches different colors
different textures of sand the
sand work.
money
love
family
entertainment
Sports
pleasure
So, how do we get out of this horrifying curse?
That's the point.
We can't.
We need someone to save us from our sins
and from ourselves.
Now for the good news, I use that phrase good
news. The main message of Christianity is also called
The Gospel.
Jesus Christ is the one holy
sinless human being who was
always in perfect harmony with God.
That is because Jesus himself is
God. He's a hundred percent God and a
hundred percent human at the same time.
Because he is sinless and perfect. He
is the only person who is qualified to
become a sacrifice for us to
take away our sin.
He died on the cross for us.
So that if we believe in him if we call on
him as Savior if we make him the Lord
Of Our Lives he will forgive us all of
our sin past present and future.
And we become a part of God's family.
We establish our houses Our Lives
upon the living bedrock.
We become saved and we get to
experience a relationship with a real and living person
Jesus.
We can be in harmony with God in our
lives.
This harmony with God is the good life that
we all imagine that we all dream of
that we all strive for.
Don't misunderstand. We're still going to have hardships and
tragedies in our lives.
Those torrential rains are going to fall. The flood is
going to come just like they did in Israel every September.
But even in the middle of that flood we can have inner peace
and a Wellspring of joy.
Jesus says in John 10:10, the thief comes
only to steal and kill and
destroy I came that. They
may have life and have it up abundantly
in the Greek. It's super
duper abundantly.
Chronicle 16 for grade is the
Lord and greatly to be praised and he is to be held in
All Above All Gods.
For all the gods of the people are idols.
But the Lord made the heavens.
Splendor and Majesty are before him
strength and Joy are in
his place.
and then Jesus says
in John 15 these things I have
spoken to you that my joy may be
in you and that your joy may
be full.
when we look at the Builder who built his house on the
sand and the flood zone we think what
were you thinking?
There's a lot.
Is in September, duh?
And yet we ourselves prioritize things in
life. We build our foundation on things other
than Jesus and we assume no flood is
ever going to come?
So what does the flood symbolize specifically theologians
focus upon four things one the
last judgment?
The Bible tells us that the end of time we will
all stand before God before his
judgment seat and give an account to
him about what we chose as the foundation.
of our life
At that time we're all going to wish we had built upon the
living Bedrock of Jesus.
death
everyone who has ever lived.
faced death
We're going to face death one day.
For some reason we all work together
to try to pretend that really isn't going to happen.
Why?
Many people at the end of their lives look back and mourn on how
they wasted their lives building their houses on the sand.
In the 1980s. It was a common saying that he who dies
with the most toys wins.
But real people on their deathbeds look at all their toys and they
say to themselves.
Vanity of vanities all is Vanity.
All a ruin a total disaster.
And facing death were all going to wish we had built Our Lives upon
the living Bedrock of Jesus.
three
crises in life
crises like floods. They're just
going to come.
I personally have experienced a stunning degree
of crises in my life.
Christies have a way of making and doing an analysis of
your life Foundation to judge what it's really
worth.
Maybe cancer or some other deadly illness has
threatened your very life.
Maybe you lost your money in the stock market and it's
left you in despair.
Maybe the love of your life betrayed you
and left you leaving you crushed.
and broken
only in Jesus is our foundation secure for
all eternity.
And then number four emptiness and unfulfillment
in life.
Sometimes even in the middle of life. We find
that what we have selected as our foundation is
deeply unfulfilling.
We feel restless and achy and empty.
We see this in popular songs.
1965 the Rolling Stones, I
can't get no.
Status faction though. I
try
two decades later 1987 Bono U2,
but I still haven't found
what I'm looking for.
2002 two decades later Johnny Cash
version of Nine Inch Nails
and you could have it all.
my Empire of dirt
will let you down.
I will make you.
know now
That's just sad.
aching emptiness causes all of us to wonder
Is that really all there is to life?
In the moment that Jesus is telling this Parable what
do the builders on the sand and the parable represent? The builders
represented people who seem to be Christians on
the outside, but who really are not
In this room right now are people who know they're
not Christians.
They're just pretending they're living a lie.
Also, there are people in this room who may be confused diluted
into thinking that they're Christians, but at some
level deep down they've got to know that Jesus isn't the real Foundation of
their lives.
Right. Now you are building your lives on something
every one of us.
Do you even know what it is?
And if you know what you're building your life upon.
Do you like your decision?
How is it working out for you now?
And how will it work out for you when the
flood comes?
So what happens to the two Builders builders on the sand
are going to end very badly.
dig and go deep
I'm a Pastor Elder here at Henderson Hills on the side been
in my paid profession if you can believe it. I'm an English professor.
Sometimes I have freshman students who never hang in an
assignment never study and almost never come to class.
When I see them exhibit this Behavior, I pull
them aside in private, and I generally ask them a few
questions.
What are you doing?
Why are you here?
I tell them that going to University is very expensive. They want
to slack off and do nothing in life. They don't have to pay College
tuition to do that.
I tell them there's going to be a reckoning at the end of
the semester a flood is coming. They're
going to get an F in all their classes and they're
gonna fail out of University.
Pretending to be a student. It's going to be a really short
ride for them.
There's some people in this room right now who seem Christian
on the outside, but who's never personally made Jesus
their lord the foundation of their lives.
I would gently ask you these questions.
What are you doing?
Why are you here?
What do you get out pretending to be
a Christian?
Why not dig and go deep into the
living Bedrock of Jesus Christ and actually become a
Christian.
There is a flood coming for all of us.
If you haven't given your life to Jesus, it's all a disaster.
complete and utter devastation
It's okay to go through the five stages of grief
like I did.
with my house
Let's go back to the story about my House's crack Foundation.
You might want to know how everything turned out.
I believe that in hindsight Devi and I we made
a good decision because in all the decades since then we've
never had a problem with that Foundation.
In fact, I felt comfortable enough with the condition of that house
that I didn't give it a second thought when I sold that
house to my own son and law Fergie and my
daughter Sheriff.
Just a few years ago.
My two glorious granddaughters Elliot and
Charis are making all their childhood memories
right there in that home just like
my daughters did.
What will your legacy be when you
dig and go deep?
When you have harmony with God and he's flowing
through you what will be the impact upon those around
you.
those you love
dig and go deep to the Bedrock Foundation of
Jesus.
What about those of us who are too true Christians who've dug deep
and went down to the living Rock. Do we sometimes become
fixated on the sands?
I have a filthy confession to make to you I do.
We all do.
That's why we sometimes don't do what Jesus tells us
to do. But Jesus is thesis in this
Parable tells us that we must be doers of the
word and not just hearers like his brother. James said
So how do we as Christians dig and go deep? The answer
is that we need to grow as Christians
over time in a process that the
Bible calls sanctific.
Ation, so builders on the Rock can melt even deeper with
the Bedrock through scientification.
That's why we need the holy spirit in our hearts
to guide us and to disciple us. That's why we
need the church. That's why we need
each other.
Christianity is not a solo sport.
Christianity is a team sport.
That's why we pray and we read the Bible and we
engage in sermons together and we
connect together in community groups and serve and
give and love.
The goal over time is to fixate less and less upon
the Sands and to rest more and more
upon the living Bedrock Jesus
so that we look more and more
like Jesus over time.
For us as Christians meditating upon this Parable helps
us to reorient our minds, especially in the chaos
of Summer to what is true and
good and best.
I seem to be known in this church as the preacher who
uses props in his sermons.
You might have thought you're going to get out of this sermon without a prop
and no such look.
As our previous lead teaching Pastor Dennis
new Kirk used to say some people think that
life.
Is like a cafeteria tray?
So this is what they do they say, okay, this is
family and this is material possessions.
And this is fun. And this is work. And
this is round we'll put Jesus right there and
we have a whole life.
But all these things are things that
Jesus has given us family and work
material possessions fun and so on. Why would
we put them equal with Jesus?
So that's the wrong notion. What is the right notion? The
right notion is that the cafeteria tray
itself is Jesus.
He is the foundation of everything in our
lives.
And the things in here family and money
and pleasure and work and all that stuff is what
he gives us and we look to him for
which order to put them in the right proportion at the
right amount. So it has the best effects in
our life for the good life.
Only through Jesus are these things
given the proper place in our
lives.
Sand is awesome.
Sand is why many of us go to the beach in the summer?
But sand is not designed to be a God for
us to worship.
We are to make a commitment. We are to dig
and go deep all the way down to the living Bedrock. That
is our Lord and Savior Jesus Christ.
Whoever you are.
Whether you're a Christian or not today.
Today is a really good day to make a commitment
to draw closer to Jesus.
The Holy Spirit may be working deep in you to make Jesus
the foundation of your life or to help you
to meld deeper to that Foundation.
Don't wait.
Don't put it off.
You can come forward to the front here at the end of the worship service. They'll
be pastors counselors eager to
care for you to listen to you to pray with you.
You can be in harmony with God today.
You can be deeply embedded deeply
melded as one to the living Rock of
Jesus Christ. Who is our Majestic
King and our almighty
God.